l'expérience du terrain et la proximité
avec les habitants c'est ce que prône
l'union pour les yvelines de la droite
et du centre elle a fait le choix d'une
liste majoritairement nouvelles avec
notamment de nombreux élus locaux je
pense que c'est important de pouvoir un
petit peu faire ses classes et est donc
je suis élu en tant que maire adjoint
depuis maintenant près de trois mandats
conseiller départemental depuis deux
mandats ça fait trente ans que je suis
élu à thoiry qu'il faut effectivement
qu'il ya des gens comme moi qu'ils
soient députés pour pouvoir défendre nos
territoires et surtout faire voter des
lois qui correspondent à la volonté des
gens et non pas seulement la volonté des
grands manitous qu'est ce qu'un député
pour eux est ce que c'est quelqu'un qui
fait simplement partie d'un groupe qui
appuie sur verre quand on lui dit des
mots clés sur verre et qui appuient ce
rouge quand on lui dit d'appeler ce
rouge ou est-ce que c'est quelqu'un qui
réfléchit par lui même qui propose des
choses qui défend des chauvauds cali
crois sincèrement c'est une liste qui
est la caractéristique d'avoir
effectivement des élus locaux
départementaux municipaux régionaux
parce que nous croyons que l'expérience
qu'ils vont qu'ils ont récupéré sur leur
terrain peut servir à l'échelon national
philippe benassaya et michel vialay sous
les deux seuls candidats sortants
l'occasion de donner une continuité au
dossier menée sur leur territoire
respectif est élu député dans 72 il va
donc je reste dans une dynamique j'ai
pas fini mon travail j'ai pas finir de
d'étudier les dossiers de recevoir la
population donc moi je suis en début de
mandat entre guillemets alors qu'on est
en fin de mandat officiellement 12
candidats qui font le choix de
s'inscrire dans une opposition
constructive à la politique
présidentielle
ils sont tous le même le président avoir
le courage de porter les réformes qu'il
apple courage de porter sur la retraite
par exemple on saura le faire sans blake
aussi utile quand un pays clé une
opposition constructive à l'assemblée
nationale
et que les électeurs et à terme un choix
autre que
maquereau ou
m chaque fois que les propositions du
gouvernement nous agrée rond nous
l'évoquerons chaque fois que les
propositions nous agrée rond dans les
grandes lignes mais avec tel ou tel
point qu'ils ne nous conviendra pas nous
les abandonnerons mais en tout cas nous
ne serons pas d'éclats coeur de pupitre
comme l'extrême droite tout comme
l'extrême gauche des candidats centrée
sur des valeurs et sujet commun le
pouvoir d'achat l'environnement la santé
la justice ou encore l'éducation ils
vont officiellement lancé leur campagne
le 13 mai lors d'une réunion publique à
bois d'arcy